how important are the connections that
you've made in your personal and
business life to your success to women
um we'll just go clockwise so charles
i'll just let you go first
all right well i have a couple anecdotes
this one is rather recent um when i
first moved to boston
um i i write a ducati i've been writing
for about 20 years by now but when i
first came uh i didn't have any friends
and
i went to some of these bike riding
events there is this charity event
called the distinguished gentleman's
ride
which raises money for
men's prostate cancer and male suicide
so they basically have hundreds of bikes
they're usually cafe racers
standards classic bikes
and everybody dresses up in tuxedos and
suits the ladies are in dresses with
peacock feathers and they would parade
around the town
i managed to build up a social circle
that way but more importantly i was at a
ducati dealership event and i met
two friends uh let's call them andrew
and jeff uh i see andrew every what at
least once every
month he came to my wedding uh you know
i'm helping him with relationship uh
troubles sometimes uh and i recently
purchased a a porsche boxster
and as you know in boston it's quite
snowy out here so you will need winter
tires uh i picked up the car in indiana
where it doesn't snow as much
jeff happens to be a porsche enthusiast
so he owns a 981 spider and he had a
boxer for 10 years he was able to help
me go through all the listings have the
inspector visit the dealership he went
over all the mechanical details with me
basically telling me whether something
is a lemon or if it's a good car we
managed to pick out a good car and not
only that he sold me his used barely
used with 18-inch winter tires tires and
rim for sixteen hundred dollars which is
less than half of his retail price and
he's going to come here on sunday and
put them on for me
so like
motorcycles and
i mean you guys know if you've read my
book i have an entire chapter on why i
think a guy should own a motorcycle at
some point in his life um you know i
really enjoyed those years i got my bike
license around 17 or 18 and i stopped
riding at 30 not permanently but just
stopped at that time um i made a lot of
great friends there's a lot of rides
that i did um
i mean i i did rides in different parts
of the world too like i've ridden
throughout europe i've also um one of my
favorite rides was actually going
through california you know where
renegade whip wingman's at doing the bay
area up to top of mount tam and it's
like just like the coolest thing being
able to get on the twisties and the
roads and just run it like everybody
talks to you when you have a bike right
it's like i guess when jeeps wave at
other jeep owners it's like pretty much
every bike owner with the exception of
like harley's will raise it you know
wave if you ride a sport bike but
you know you get a head nod you get a
hand wave something like that right it's
almost like an automatic brotherhood and
i think the thing with ducati's that's
unique i never owned a duck it was
mostly you know the japanese crotch
rockets but do you get special invites
to ducati owner events like you know
dinners galas
like road trips or anything like that
there are
like ducati riders clubs um i was in
denver and they have a very large ducati
community the dealership there over by
walnut it's a street um
they organize a lot of the social events
uh and they also have like rock and roll
concert bands here in new england
because it snows half the year uh the
community is quite a bit smaller but we
also have you know as far as the marquee
itself we would get together and watch
moto gp right so they would have regular
sunday events and we would watch moto gp
yeah
yeah it's a really good community to get
and it's not expensive i mean even a
nice motorcycle of ducati like like
what's the barrier to entry on that like
10 15 grand for use one
so it depends on what
age you could pick up a beginner's
monster 696 or about 6 000 which is what
i just sold uh one for and it's very low
mileage it's about 3 000. and are you
accepted into the group if you show up
with a monster 696 or is it kind of like
yeah okay
people are not that discriminative i
mean you know we all ride bikes we all
enjoy the same thing you know you're
you're just a brother or a sister like
the rest of us
got it got it um 50 shades
yeah um i would say
network is 90
to me
you know um building a network whatever
city i've been and i lived in 50
different or four different states out
of the 50 and a bunch of different
cities and i've always found um if you
attend um go to the local political
party i don't care you know well i do
care what side you're on but you know
um if if you go to
party meetings party events you're gonna
get people from all age ranges all
business backgrounds absolutely
everything and it's just it's just it's
it's i refer to um networking as kind of
business game
you know you got to have some of the
very same skills that you have when
you're engaging with women you got to
have you got to know when to back away
you meet someone who's way up the food
chain it's gonna be a hello how are you
doing see if you have anything in common
walk away maybe come back later you know
you can't engage somebody full on and
and and pushing from the start
but i've you know i've built a huge
network and
you know just small example here locally
and one of my urge buddies is a pretty
major contractor
and
instead of me having to vet
subcontractors or workers for my house
i'll just ask him i'll say i need a good
electrician i need a good landscaper and
a good hardscaper and a good pool guy
and he'll just tell me this guy's the
best this guy's the best and this other
guy is i don't have to worry about any
of the rest of the stuff
so
what was the most valuable um
organization group
whatever that you joined that expanded
your network 50 shades
um
it i would say a lot of the uh
oh god the republican party circles i
ended up in but also the car
yeah the car you know you're gonna like
get a lot of
clowns and idiots but um
i would say car yeah i go to car meets
as well and it's the exact same thing
someone breaks out a cigar and and you
know what it's like
ninety percent of the guys at a car meet
are not gonna be
you know it doesn't matter what they're
driving they're gonna be eager to show
it to you and people are swapping
business cards and
it's just
yapping the app back and forth like um
2000 and 2006 just for example i
you know i i met a bunch of uh irish
um irish american
you know guys of irish descent who were
big in the republican party and they
were all older than me i was hanging out
with them in new york blah blah and they
just called me up one day and they said
what are you doing for st patrick's day
and i said usual said want to come to
the white house
i was like you're serious and they were
like yeah so i spent st patrick's day
2006 at the um irish um prime minister's
thing at the white house you know
handing over to shamrock and all that
crap okay that just goes to show you the
power of networking you go from
you know being a nobody in new york city
to drinking out of the white house china
and flipping the board to tourists out
the window um
on st patrick's day
actually
jason what's the um what's the deal in
texas like what's your experience been
with networking
uh you know i'm a firm believer that you
will not survive if you don't have a
pretty big network i mean it's just
uh whether that's social or professional
my entire career was built on building a
network uh real estate is one of those
businesses where
it is you know people think they go
online and that's how you buy a property
and especially when we start to get into
commercial real estate it's all
networking
it's all you know one of my good buddies
is uh
he's a partner in the largest commercial
brokerage in the state so when i'm
looking for something i call them up go
hey man you guys got any this is kind of
what i'm looking for
and even if they don't have it i could
bounce ideas hey we're looking at this
kind of deal what do you you know what
are your thoughts that sort of thing so
it is
it is critical if you're one of these
guys that just kind of sits inside all
time and plays video games you're kind
of missing out on the bigger game here
there is uh there is ample opportunity
out there to do whatever you want with a
whole group of people
and uh i tell you one of the one of the
things you will find is the more
successful you be
out there
so
oh is he breaking up for you guys too
yeah
all right jason we're gonna we're gonna
put you on put you on ice for a minute
because you're breaking up with the
connection i'll i'll throw it over to
moff um i'll come back to in a minute
though but moff yes same question so
you're up in the northeast
um what's
what's been the best uh way for you to
network and level up like what have you
found works
it's been this group itself man um you
know it's being in new york city there's
no
i'm more concerned with finding
red-pilled guys um
but even funneling down to red-pilled
successful guys
and
i think that i share i think i'm more
one of the common guys out there that i
think a lot of people resonate with my
experience being one of the younger guys
in the group you know not being an
entrepreneur not running a business and
doing my small stuff on the side with
like coaching and things like that but
i'm still in corporate world like i
still am i'm a software sales guy for
uh you know a company here and based in
new york so um for me
sort of what 50 shades mentioned really
resonates it's you know i want to be
able to have a guy for this and a guy
for that and not because
i want to be able to say you know i can
ask for favors but i want to see guys
that i like and guys that i can resonate
with and help them and see them level up
so they can pass that along
and uh you know help others do the same
so i mean for me like the one percent
group the the community we built here
is i mean the majority of the guys that
i talk to and spend time with
uh bounce business ideas off of bounce
dating advice ideas off of one of the
big goals and priorities that it's been
for me since we had our miami trip about
a month ago was
you know i'm not gonna be able to go
into a networking event or a car event
or a ceo entrepreneur's event and tell
guys how to run their business these
titans of these industry but
being in this space for about a year now
and seeing a lot of the stories out
there you know i've run into dozens if
not hundreds of guys and heard dozens of
guys stories that are like yeah man i'm
crushing it in life in business but my
wife only sleeps with me on my birthday
and on christmas and so those are the
guys i want to talk to you and say okay
like where are we falling short you know
where can i add value
uh
to these kind of guys so you know
that's that's been the biggest thing for
me is and i'm sure that we'll talk more
about that but for me it's about this
group
and then
building those genuine relationships
it's more so about how do i be a guy
that people want to talk to and be
around
uh and a lot of that starts with just
being socially calibrated so that's how
i try to go into every interaction yeah
i want to i want to talk about the miami
trip in the show too so so we'll come
back to that uh jason how's your
connection are you good now
i hope so i think i'm right next to the
internet right here so who knows
we lost you for about five seconds so
just i saw that everybody stopped all of
a sudden everybody stopped all of a
sudden i was like oh it's not it's it's
definitely not them um you know i think
the the most important piece and this is
actually something i heard from aaron
clary of all folks where he said at some
point you you run up the success track
where you become peerless
and that's not really a good place to be
if you guys read the 48 laws of power so
what i have found is what i've done
lately is now i'm getting groups of guys
together at least locally that are
really successful we have these success
dinners where we and they're all just
different industries so we're at some
high-end restaurant somewhere in town
and it's you know five ten guys you know
over old fashions and whiskey and sushi
and all that hey what are you guys doing
what are you struggling with in your
business that sort of thing and um
you will find that that you know that
old
that old saying that hey the more
successful you you get the more lonely
it is at the top and that's 100 percent
true so you're always looking for where
are those other guys trying to keep you
know continue to push the envelope and
that's where networking becomes
absolutely critical
so just to add to that another good
resource a
a good friend of mine wrote a book on
amazon called mastermind dinners uh let
me just make sure it's still on uh
it's still on amazon because um this was
his thing like he was a big uh connector
on events before covid hit
um let me see here just make sure it's
still on
is it jason gaynord yeah you got it
there it is so it's still up i wasn't
sure if it was still up i'll just throw
it up on the screen i'm not gonna bother
dropping a link you guys can go and you
know search for it real quick but if
you're listening to the podcast an audio
version just go to amazon and search for
mastermind dinners the author's name is
jason gaynard uh g-a-i-g-n-a-r-d
um this guy
i've never seen anybody as connected as
jay is and the people that he puts
together in fact if you go back to my
really old videos in the uh channel from
like 2015 2016 uh i got a video with jay
in my old m3 convertible and we got hit
by like this tornado wind storm when we
were driving
but we had a really interesting
conversation during that drive if you
guys want to dig it up but if you want
to learn how to host dinners
and connect people at these dinners in
the best way possible i'd recommend
reading this book
[Music]
i think i found my calling
dude that's awesome yeah yeah i'll tell
you one of the things everybody ought to
do everyone needs to have a meet up
like you guys all ought to run a meet up
in your own it doesn't matter it could
be over real estate or you know whatever
you're doing but i will tell you that
has become invaluable because now all of
a sudden you become seen as a thought
leader because you can stand in front of
a room and talk for five minutes you
know what even if even if you don't have
much value to offer because you're lower
down the total like even when i was
young like even when i was 17 18 years
old and all i had was
20 bucks in my pocket and a motorcycle i
would still go to the coffee shop pretty
much
four nights maybe five nights a week
meet up with my friends we'd shoot the
[ __ ] in the parking lot we'd race down
you know the old bypass where there was
no
uh places for cops to hide and we just
go back and like you know
grind each other's gears grab a coffee
you know smash a few donuts shoot some
more [ __ ] talk to girls you know all
that stuff you know just get in the
habit of being social and networking
with people and continue to do that even
if you're introverted like i'll be
honest with you guys like sometimes you
might think that oh that's very easy for
you to say but
again i'm being perfectly honest i'm
very introverted like i i actually
prefer my own company i don't like large
crowds i was never big on like you know
the nightclub scene even though i spent
a lot of time in it i just like tight
groups of good people is what my
preference is which is one of the
reasons why why i actually put together
my uh community was because i wanted to
build something where like-minded guys
could get together and chop up ideas and
we've been improving it you know like
every year as it as it goes on um yeah
but it starts somewhere for everybody
right jay
yeah it's i i am a firm but this is one
of the things that when i tell folks
like if i could if i could do my real
estate business all over again
starting day one i would have um
i would have started up a meetup group
to talk about even though i was brand
new in the business didn't know what i
was doing but the fact that you can just
send out an email put a post on social
media and get everybody in a room and
talk about it it is invaluable and i'll
tell you this a lot this is a big
misconception
uh there is a belief out there that
folks that are at a much higher level
don't want to help the guys that are
coming up and that's absolutely not true
uh a lot of times at least what i've
found and what's been my experience is
you know you put in a little bit of
effort the folks that are ahead of you
absolutely love to mentor guys coming up
because most people don't want to do the
work
and they and they talk to plenty of
people like oh i'd love to be as rich as
you i'm like okay well this is how you
do it and they're like whoa wait a
second i don't i don't want to do that
well okay well you don't get to then you
don't get all the cool stuff
so
uh putting those groups together even if
you're a guy that's not really
accomplished yet
you can learn a lot and like i said you
can create some really great contacts
for guys that are way ahead of you that
are willing to mentor you along and
teach you you know how not to make the
same mistakes they did
you